what's going on everyone axel beats here
for anime uproar and recently we did a
video talking about all of luffy's forms
and since you guys seemed to enjoy that
video so much we thought it might be fun
to talk about all the straw hats in kind
of the same way i think one of my
favorite parts of the straw hats is that
each of them is so unique and they each
offer something special that makes them
stand out but no one is perfect and
while each of them is incredibly strong
on their own the real strength of the
straw hat crew is that they can each
cover for each other's weak points and
that they believe in each other
wholeheartedly they are a perfect
example of something that is greater
than the sum of its parts but that said
there are a lot of parts as there are 10
members as of right now so we should
probably not waste any more time with
the intro before we get into the video
though if you're enjoying our one piece
content and you want to see more in the
future be sure to leave a like so that
we know to keep making it and if you're
new to anime uproar be sure to hit that
subscribe button to stay up to date on
everything we put out with all the
youtube stuff out of the way though
let's get into the video spoilers and
all now obviously if we're talking about
the straw hats we should probably start
with luffy but because we just did a
video on him i'll be covering him as
quickly as i can here despite being told
for 25 years that luffy had eaten the
gum gum fruit we recently learned that
it was actually the hitohito nomi model
nika a mythical zone named after the sun
god nika a hero who fought for
liberation for all that all comes a
little bit later though as most of the
fancy bits of the fruit come out when
the fruit is awakened but the basics of
the fruit are that they will turn the
user's body into rubber meaning luffy is
able to stretch bounce resist
electricity all the things that we know
rubber to be able to do the majority of
luffy's attacks involve him stretching
his limbs back and slingshotting them
forward with things like the gum gum
pistol gum gum bazooka or the gum gum
spear but his rubber body isn't all for
offense it gives him a ton of mobility
in being able to reach high or far away
points which can be combined with gum
gum rocket to send him flying anywhere
he needs to go he can also use gum gum
ufo which kind of lets him float for a
bit of time the fruit also gives him
some protection with options like gum
gum balloon or by treating himself like
a trampoline or tarp that springs things
like cannonballs people or bullets off
of himself luffy can also bump up his
abilities by using his gear forms gear
second has him pumping the blood and
oxygen through his body faster something
that makes himself much faster and
stronger as a result this also opens up
the jet series of attacks which are more
or less upgrades of his usual stuff add
in hockey and you have the hawk eagle
and rock series of attacks as well gear
third has him blowing into his thumbs to
inflate his bones and allow him to
create giant punches kicks or whatever
else he might need here you have attacks
given the giant title and just like in
gear second when you add in haki you get
some animal named attacks like elephant
gun and grizzly magnum something kind of
fun between the first three forms as
well is that each of them has a
different elemental based attack water
luffy appears when he's in his normal
form the fiery red hawk is his second
gear ability and the electrified thor
elephant gun shows up in gear third it's
nothing super important but it is kind
of a cute theming structure that shows
up onto fourth gear along with three new
forms bound man focuses on elastic
compression and release to give a
massive boost to luffy's attacks his
range is shorter but to make up for that
he can basically fly and he hits hard
enough to even take out doflamingo when
using this form it's not my favorite
form but i'd definitely be lying if i
didn't say that king kong gun wasn't one
of the most satisfying attacks in the
series it's also something i really
appreciate because of this elastic
compression idea which doesn't really
show up too often in the rest of luffy's
arsenal the more defensive option for
gear fourth is tank man basically
removing all of luffy's mobility but
allowing him to eat almost unlimitedly
as well as to coat himself with haki
that is so durable that cracker can't
pierce through it we all know that this
is the lamest form luffy has there's not
much to talk about with it so let's just
move on to gear fourth snake man luffy
trades off all of his defense and bulk
for speed his punches become faster the
longer that they're traveling and by
using python he's able to change the
direction of his attacks mid-air
basically turning every one of his moves
into a homing attack and finally we have
the newly discovered gear fifth where
luffy awakens the nika fruit and becomes
the embodiment of nika and joyboy his
hair turns white he gets this ribbon or
sash-like thing that's really similar to
something you might see on japanese
deities like fujin and raijin for
example and in this form luffy is only
limited by his imagination he can change
anything around him into rubber change
his own shape to become giant or to wrap
around the attacks of his opponents and
the world around him seems to become
more cartoonish
eyes popping out of people's heads wonky
physics it's basically like we are all
in the last few minutes of space jam
where michael jordan realizes he can use
cartoon powers while he's in the looney
tune world but just on a bigger scale
like i said we do have a more fleshed
out description of luffy's forms over in
last week's video but for now let's move
on to our second crew member and the
first mate
zorro zorro is a swordsman focusing on
three sword style carrying one sword in
each hand and one in his mouth this
stems from the time when he was in ishin
dojo where he started picking up as many
swords as he could because he thought it
would make him more powerful in a fight
against queena he originally picked up
so many that he couldn't even hold them
but eventually he settled on the 3 sword
style that we know and love throughout
the series zoro has gone through several
named swords his first and most iconic
sword was the wado ichimonji which was
inherited after kawina's death
he then picked up yubashiri and the
sandai ketsu in logtown kotetsu was
supposedly a cursed sword however zoro
proved his luck to be greater than that
curse and the owner of the shop was so
impressed by zoro that he gifted him the
yuba shiri as recognition for his talent
and intuition yubashiri would eventually
be destroyed by shu at emmy's lobby with
his rust rust abilities and it would go
on to be replaced in thriller bark after
zoro defeated the revived ryuma as ryuma
would pass on to the afterlife shusui
was given to zoro he would keep shusui
all the way until wano when gukimaru
stole it and zoro would make the
decision to return it to ryuma's grave
in exchange for enma the sword odin used
to cut kaido and leave the scar across
his chest
that said while enma is a supremely
powerful sword it drains a ton of
armament haki from its user which can
leave them feeling extremely weak and
all of that leaves zoro with two
owwazumono or great grade swords being
the warawichimonji and enma as well as a
wasamono sword being the sendai kotetsu
a pretty respectable lineup so let's
cover a few more of zoro's more famous
attacks and abilities onigiri makes use
of all three swords to cut through his
enemies this or variations of it tend to
be zoro's go-to finisher move tatsumaki
or dragon twister uses a spinning slash
to create a tornado-like attack that is
more effective when he's surrounded by
enemies zoro also has some ranged
attacks as well those being the 36 72
and 108 caliber phoenix basically this
allows him to compress air with his
attacks and launch them at enemies like
a cannon something to note here is that
these attacks fit into the category of
zoro's abilities which are inspired by
buddhism with there being 36 earthly
desires 72 stupas and 108 being the
number of mantras spoken in devotional
meditation we also see this theming kind
of showing up in zorro's most iconic and
unfortunately underutilized ability that
being asura or the nine sword style
zorro creates the illusion of gaining
two extra heads and four arms that makes
him resemble the god asura in general
zoro also gets a bit of an upgrade once
he has enma as he begins to use king of
hell three sword style basically enma
draws out as much hockey as possible and
infuses it into all of zoro's swords
increasing his strength and the range of
his attacks this does drain him
incredibly quickly and could even be
lethal so it has to be used in very
small doses this form also gives off
black lightning and green smoky aura as
well furthermore it's fair to say that
in any of these forms zoro would be able
to cut through flames at this point as
he has learned kinamon's foxfire style
zorro also has access to his two-sword
style one sword style or even no sword
style to make up for occasions where he
loses his swords most of these attacks
just tend to be variants of their three
sword style counterparts though there
are a few unique abilities like for
example two sword style having rashomon
clear lance or even the iconic one
gorilla 2 gorilla outside of his attacks
zorro has a few extra traits that really
affect his character as well zoro has no
sense of direction however he is
incredibly lucky and thus often ends up
where he needs to be anyways we see this
in sabaodi where he ends up at the
auction house
entirely by accident he's incredibly
physically strong we all remember the
scene of him lifting weights very early
on in the series and he's much more
durable than any average normal human
finally the biggest thing zoro has to
offer outside of his insane strength is
a sense of duty and loyalty to the crew
more specifically to the captain of the
crew he will always side with luffy's
decisions in the end but he's also
willing to call him out when he would
make a choice that would be unbecoming
for a leader or which would make him
look weak the best example of this would
be allowing usopp back on the crew
before he apologized for disrespecting
luffy making the case that if we allow
usot back on the crew now what's to stop
anyone else from trying to leave the
crew and then jumping back whenever they
feel like it and speaking of usopp he is
our third official crew member usopp is
our marksman specializing in long ranged
attacks but in general being a bit of a
coward especially early on post time
skip he's a little bit more willing to
be in the fray but i would definitely
still say he's extra cautious at the
very least usopp has a natural ability
for all things projectile being able to
pick up things like slingshots and
cannons almost immediately and even more
so usopp has the ability to hit targets
far beyond the norm first being seen in
the filler episode with daddy masterson
but more iconically and more canonically
in annie's lobby when he was able to
snipe spawndom with his slingshot from a
range that made it impossible for
spawndom soldiers with guns to retaliate
with the soldiers even saying that a
shot like that would be impossible and
with the addition of observation hockey
usopp was even able to stop sugar on
dressrosa from an ungodly distance
outside of sniping though usopp also has
a pretty impressive level of durability
for being one of the most normal people
on the crew usopp can take an absolute
beating on the battlefield and keep
fighting one that stands out for me is
always his fight with miss merry
christmas and mr four where he was
completely demolished in the fight but
would keep getting up of course he also
is a very talented runner so if he can
avoid all of that he probably will
another of usop's innate talents for
better or worse is telling lies while
this isn't always effective usopp can
often bluff his opponents bolster his
allies morale at least the gullible ones
who believe him or even open up some
opportunities for his crew usopp while
not being the official shipwright of the
crew is also fairly capable of some
minor engineering and carpentry enough
to keep the mary going from syrup
village over reverse mountain through
waffle eating parts of her going up to a
sky island through the knock-up stream
and falling back down to the ocean mary
went through an incredibly rough time
and without usop's minor repairs she
probably would have never made it all
the way to water 7. speaking of water 7
we also see here that usopp has undying
loyalty and this can kinda be a blessing
or a curse he is loyal to the mary to
the point that he can't see that she is
beyond her time and the fact that luffy
is unable to see his delusions causes a
rift between them that said going back
to that miss merry christmas fight we
also see who's not having that same kind
of dedication for luffy when she
disrespects luffy's dream usopp in
general is kind of a jack of all trades
he can offer a little bit of support in
just about any field he's a decent
artist he cuts hair he gardens and he
can even create weapons for the crew
that are as complex as the climate act
finally usopp is great at being creative
on the battlefield he is far from the
strongest on the crew however he's often
coming up with plans that can help him
overcome the odds to defeat an opponent
who's much stronger than he is even
early on we saw him taking on fish men
like chu or if we go back to water 7 in
his fight with luffy he does pretty damn
well in keeping up with him and because
of this i would say usop's greatest
strength is probably not actually his
sniping but instead his ingenuity and
clever tactics on the battlefield to
make any situation into one where he can
even the odds or overcome them speaking
of usop on the battlefield though let's
talk about some of usopp's weapons and
tools his first slingshot the ginga
pachinko was more or less a basic kid's
toy and often just fired rocks but usof
also shot things like eggs tabasco balls
lead balls minor explosives smoke bombs
flaming pellets or shuriken a really
diverse set of tools for dealing with
any situation when he gets to annie's
lobby as sniper king he swaps to kabuto
a much larger slingshot with a lot more
power and this tended to offer larger
scale versions of the basic slingshot
attacks which included increased range
number of pellets and power for each
shot post time skip we swapped the
original kabuto for the kuro kabuto
which is not just a much more manageable
size but it's also a living weapon this
version has the ability to grow in size
after being fed water it can also eat
the debris around it to fill up ammo for
usopp to launch it also has a super grow
up version the great kuru kabuto which
was used to fire off the bagworm star a
super long ranged attack that has
boosters within it to propel an attack
over an insane distance this is the one
used against sugar outside of slingshots
usop has a variety of hammers the usop
hammer is just a normal mallet whereas
the usop 5 ton hammer is a fake
basically it's two frying pans on a
stick with paper mache to make it look
like a hammer it's ultimately just used
to scare or fool his opponents and more
or less the same could be said for the
10 or 100 ton variants they're all just
pranks he plays on his enemies he also
has other tools like caltrops nails on a
chalkboard grappling hooks spring shoes
suction shoes and other just general use
tools as well after skypia usop also
introduces dials into his arsenal
although they do get used less often
after the time skip these dials include
tone dials to record audio breath dials
to store air or gas impact dials to
store kinetic energy and flash dials to
store light finally usopp also has pop
greens at his disposal these seeds are
dangerous plants that grow extremely
quickly he launches them through his
slingshot to essentially summon things
like venus flytraps seaweed shields
refleccia flowers bamboo exploding grass
and a bunch of other options usopp in a
sense is the ultimate utility character
offering a bit of ability in every field
and specific talent with long ranged
attacks what he does best though is
enables his crewmates to succeed as well
as making the best out of any situation
that he finds himself in and that brings
us to our fourth official crewmate and
the final member of the monster trio
along with luffy and zorro
sanji the cook of the crew is a fighter
who focuses on leg-based combat as a
chef shouldn't be risking their hands in
battle you can cook if your legs are
injured but if your hands are out of
commission you can't really do a whole
lot in terms of what he offers the crew
as the chef he ensures that the
crewmates are healthy and avoid
malnutrition he's also in charge of
storing and shopping for food as well in
terms of his role on the battlefield
sanji is easily one of the strongest
members of the crew however he's often
used in a more espionage-like way while
being one of the strongest crewmates he
is also among the most stealthy later
being exemplified with his raid suit's
ability to turn him invisible
many arcs see sanji vanishing early on
to deal with things in the background
which end up being vital for the success
of the mission for example in any lobby
as luffy is fighting rob luci and the
rest of the crew is fighting marine
lieutenants on the bridge sanji
disappears for a bit to close the gates
of justice something which ended up
being disastrous for the marine ships
and allowed the straw hats to escape
similar things can be seen all over the
story like in alabasta when he acted as
mr prince as well so if usopp offers
small scale changes in momentum for
individual fights sanji is able to look
at the big picture and offer a solution
to what will eventually be the biggest
problem of the arc sanji has a bit of a
leg up in terms of most fights as he's a
vinsmoke just like his siblings he was
modified by his father while his mother
was pregnant to have superhuman
abilities his mother did take a drug to
repress this so sanji could keep his
emotions but this resulted in him being
born more or less as a normal person
however it seems as though as of his
fight with queen all of his genetic
enhancements have been fully awakened
after awakening he essentially has an
exoskeleton protecting him as well as
his superhuman body he is faster
stronger and more durable than he was
before all while also adding in an
accelerated healing for example queen
basically crushes sanji to near death
and breaks most of his bones
to which sanji just stands back up snaps
himself back into place and begins
healing even when queen tries to cut him
with a sword the sword just shatters on
sanji's head sanji is also fast enough
to vanish before queen and strong enough
to completely overtake queen all of
which was out of the question before he
awakened and it seems to be that wearing
the raid suit was the trigger that
allowed him to awaken something which
very much bothered sanji as he already
tried to cut ties with his family so he
decides to destroy the suits canister as
a symbolic final jump away from them
that said while his body might have been
something that he got from judge and
vinsmoke science his fighting style was
instead learned from his adopted father
zeph that being blackleg style this is a
much more acrobatic way of fighting
relying on only his legs and it's only
made more powerful once he learns to
combine it with things like blue walk
and skywalk we'll often now see him
jumping up as high as he possibly can
before plummeting down with high
momentum so that he can get extra power
out of his kicks and that brings us to
sanji's most iconic attack diabla jean
originally set up by spinning quickly in
place but now can be triggered much more
easily the ablazomb allows sanji to heat
up his legs until it's glowing bright
red resulting in kicks that can even
light his enemies on fire this is later
enhanced in wano as the ifrit jump by
using the genetic enhancements in
combination with armament haki he can
ramp up his legs to even higher heat
until the flames turn blue and become
much more deadly while sanji is a
monumentally important and valuable
member of the crew he does have a major
weakness though that's of course being
women sanji is unable to hit women even
in a fight to the death against one for
example he could not get himself to
fight caulifla even though she was
trying to kill him and robin's life was
on the line on top of that he's much
more willing to just go along with
anything a woman says if she flirts with
him setting him up to fall into several
traps along the series however this
sense of chivalry is kind of core to who
he is so it's equal parts pathetic and
admirable now some other just niche
abilities that sanji has showed off
throughout the series include the
ability to
kick someone into being beautiful as
seen with duvall as well as using knives
in combat pretty expertly in his fight
against wanzi on the puffing tom now on
to our final east blue member the
navigator nami
there's always the joke that luffy and
zoro would never have made it out of the
east blue without nami and i think
that's absolutely true luffy might lead
the crew but nami gets them to where
they need to go
nami has two assets that really make her
special as well as several other talents
that all combine to make her invaluable
to the crew
firstly she is extremely smart while
usof and luffy might be out of the box
thinkers nami is a great in-the-box
thinker she's able to look at the world
around her in a much more down-to-earth
way and make plans based on math and
science second is nami's unique ability
to sense weather changes with her body
for example being able to predict
cyclones storms or hurricanes well
before they happen and buy her crew
enough time to react and move to safety
this especially on the grand line has
probably been more vital to keeping the
crew alive than even things like luffy
zoro or sanji's strength you can't win a
fight if you don't survive long enough
to show up to it after all when you
combine her ability to detect weather
with her knowledge of science and
meteorology you get a character who is
able to help the straw hats navigate
through the grand line despite the
insane weather climates and while it
doesn't get too much time to shine in
the series nami is also an expert
cartographer as well which could easily
be used to the crew's advantage anytime
they need to scout out an area in battle
nami is an expert in manipulating and
using weather to her advantage even
against someone like enel she was able
to deflect some of his lightning-based
attacks by thinking quickly and using
thunderballs speaking of weather nami
uses it to essentially become the mage
of the group she typically does this by
means of the climate act a tool first
created by usop
to primarily perform party tricks but
which could also create cool or warm
pockets of air by manipulating these
nami is able to create illusions with
mirage tempo or even perform powerful
lightning attacks with thunderbolt tempo
after skypia the climb attack would be
upgraded to the perfect climate act with
the inclusion of dials these allowed her
to have greater control on the weather
and perform her old abilities much more
easily mirage tempo gets bumped up to
mirage tempo fata morgana thunderbolt
tempo is strong enough to wipe out an
entire group of marines and new attacks
like thunder lance tempo become
available to her however while the name
perfect climb attack implies the weapon
has no flaws and is in its peak form it
doesn't really offer her the ability to
control lightning very well and because
of that her allies often get caught in
the blasts post time skip we see another
evolution in the sorcery climate act her
lightning is now strong enough to blow
up a bar and mirage tempo can make her
appear completely invisible for a short
time she also gets access to more
wind-based attacks like gust sword as
well you see her using weather eggs like
heat egg which can launch a ball that
will eventually pop and affect the area
around them and the final form of the
climate act so far is the sorcery
climate act second model taking the
science she learned in witheria and
combining it with usop's pop greens and
frankie's mechanical mind the climb
attack becomes much easier to wield it
can grow it can shrink it spins more
easily and leaves patterns in the air
after being used which give off this
more magical feel nami of course would
go on to capture zeus within the climate
act which allows her to supercharge her
lightning attacks eventually zeus's soul
would even bind the weapon making it
sentient and enhancing its abilities
even further zeus is also able to
transfer his consciousness into the
clouds that nami creates to make her
attacks even more accurate and deadly of
course nami has more than just weather
to offer her crew though as she also
acts as the crew's treasurer she keeps
luffy from blowing their money on things
like giant bronze statues of himself and
delegates the crew's funds to ensure
that the crew has enough money for food
repairs and anything else that they
might need and it definitely helps that
she's incredibly stingy as well often
negotiating for better prices as well as
making sure that the straw hats don't
get scammed something that we see in
water 7 after they collected a small
fortune worth of gold on skypia and the
berry exchanger was going to rip them
off and negotiation goes beyond just
money for nami she's able to manipulate
fool and entice people regularly to win
them over we see this with zeus lola and
countless other people throughout the
series but this idea of her being
someone who can win people over also
leans into nami being our resident spy
and thief
her and sanji kind of play the behind
the scenes actors of the crew but in
different ways sanji often opens
opportunities for the rest of the crew's
success on a larger scale while nami is
better on a more personal level and
finally the epitome of nami's character
her ability to make money and her
ability to take advantage of those
around her and by far
her most effective attack
is obviously the happiness punch where
she flashes all the dudes around her and
charges them a hundred thousand berries
each in seriousness though nami offers a
lot of intangible keys to success that
the crew needs she's the glue that holds
the crew together and she holds everyone
accountable making sure that they are
all doing what they need to do and not
acting on impulse while every crew
member is vitally important to the
crew's survival it would pretty easily
be argued that nami is the key to all of
it now on to the next straw hat and one
who's in charge of the straw hat's very
survival on a much more literal level
this is chopper the ship's doctor he
learned creativity and passion for the
craft of medicine from hero look and
some of the best medicine sciences in
the world from dr kureha then learning
even more medical skills on torino
island as well while also boasting
medical feats like treating zanesha's
leg keeping luffy and zoro alive on
countless occasions and even curing
queen's mummy virus with ease now it's
kind of hard to accurately talk about
chopper's medical abilities as
i am not a doctor and i don't understand
even basic science at all but he does
keep everyone safe and it's extremely
rare for him to ever not be able to cure
what ails them and i think that's what
really matters
what i can talk about is his devil fruit
abilities chopper is a blue nosed
reindeer who ate the hitohito nomi the
human human fruit giving him the ability
to speak and think on a higher level as
he was already an animal chopper is
essentially able to speak to and
understand anyone be they human fish man
or animal as with all zone fruits this
fruit offers chopper three forms his
base reindeer form which is good at
mobility and speed a human form which
looks more like a sasquatch or ape man
honestly but it does offer him a ton of
brute strength and his hybrid form which
is the one he uses most often it's small
it's often confused for a tanooki or a
raccoon dog but it's often his go-to
when he needs to think quickly however
chopper is a unique zone fruit user
while eating his own fruit typically
offers you two additional forms to your
normal body chopper manages to create
the rumble ball with his medicine this
adding an additional four jumping point
gives him long legs which allow him to
leap far distances
guard point puffs out his fur and works
more or less like luffy's gum gum
balloon basically making him too fluffy
to harm from any physical attacks arm
point makes his arms more muscle bound
and gives him pretty devastating power
and hornpoint extends his antlers and
allows him to tackle or throw his
opponents now that said the rumble ball
only lasts for about 3 minutes and can
only be eaten safely once every 6 hours
at least at first in the event that
chopper is pushed the edge and needs to
take more rumble balls he puts himself
at risk and in an emergency where he
needs to take a third rumble ball he
will enter monster point a large
behemoth-like form that is completely
out of control and will attack anyone
around him regardless of if their friend
or foe post time skip chopper can use
all of his forms pretty freely with the
exception of monster point which still
requires one rumble ball however now he
is able to control that form on top of
this chopper's horn and guard point are
stronger after the two year jump and a
new form kung fu point is created which
gives him quick movements and strong
impacts on his attacks it's kind of the
best of both arm and jumping point
finally with caesar clown's help chopper
is able to extend the time limit for
rumble balls from 3 to 30 minutes at the
expense of entering an infant-like state
after it wears off because chopper has
so many forms he's kind of an
all-arounder on the battlefield he
offers a little bit of everything and is
versatile enough to have decent options
in most fights that he finds himself in
that said he fits the description of
jack of all trades master of none while
he does okay i wouldn't really say he's
particularly powerful on his own
especially in comparison to some of the
enemies that we're coming across now if
i had to rank him i'd say he's probably
the weakest straw hat with the
possibility that monster point can make
him extremely relevant in fights for
short bursts on average though chopper
probably fits somewhere in the group of
nami and usop not the strongest by a
mile but in terms of utility they offer
quite a lot next up is my personal
favorite straw hat the resident
archaeologist and the only person on the
crew who isn't actually a crazy person
well at least until jinbei joins that
being nico robin the sole survivor of
ohara and the last person who could read
the ponoglyphs and who is without a
question going to be the key to finding
laughtale her role in the story will
only become more important as it
continues and gets closer and closer to
its end robin is well informed on the
state of the world and has general
knowledge of most relevant people places
and histories making her incredibly
valuable in general basically nami
allows the straw hats to make good and
responsible choices and robin allows
them to make well-informed choices
there's also something to be said about
robin's ability to survive since she was
8 years old the world government has
been hunting for her and by means of
escape finding people to work for or
with or taking advantage of those she
comes across she managed to stay alive
all while staying informed enough about
the world at large to make the moves
that she needed to do to stay free we
even see some of these skills coming in
clutch in wano country as she needs to
assume a false identity as a geisha for
much of the opening acts through her
years on the run robin acted as a spy a
thief an assassin and really anything
else that she might have needed to do in
the moment offering her a very diverse
set of skills all of this without even
mentioning her devil fruit the hana
hananomi or the flower flower fruit
which allows her body parts to bloom
anywhere she sees fit basically she can
grow extra arms legs hands eyes ears or
even an entire clone of herself which
can appear anywhere within her range
most iconically she grows arms on the
back of her opponents which reach up
grab their heads and yank them backwards
to crack their spine she also does
smaller things like slaps stomps rolling
people on the floor twisting frankie's
nuts and bolts or binding winged enemies
to stop them from flying these can also
be done in combination as well as she's
not limited to summoning one kind of
body part she can sprout multiple hands
at once to create wings to allow her to
fly for a moment or to create gigantic
limbs which can be used to attack her
enemies or protect her allies robin's
devil fruit is easily one of the most
powerful within the first half of the
series allowing her to take out massive
swarms of enemies easily while staying
extremely safe herself honestly if they
weren't a logia user or something
specifically built to resist her there's
a good chance robin could hold her own
against just about anyone even
characters as strong as zoro would
pretty easily have their necks cracked
and there's not a whole lot he could do
about it that said plenty of the
pre-time skipped characters do
specifically resist her crocodile the
admirals enel and ace are all logia
users and her hands would either go
through them or be severely damaged
characters who are very hard like josu
or flexible like luffy would also not
really be affected as well characters
like magellan who is coated in poison or
mr two who can become swords are also
pretty dangerous for her to grab as the
biggest weakness of her fruit is that
the limbs she create can be damaged and
she will feel the injury and i mean
grabbing onto a sword probably not the
best idea that said i'm not exactly sure
how magellan's poison would work as it
isn't like the limbs are going back into
her so the poison would likely just
vanish after she feels the pain from
touching it and another great example of
someone fairly weak that robin probably
wouldn't be able to beat in a fight is
even someone like buggy the clown she
can't grab his neck because he would
just pop it off so while her devil fruit
is immensely powerful there's about a
million ways to get around it post time
skip though robin seems to be able to
produce more limbs she has an easier
time making giant limbs and can even
incorporate fish man karate into her
attacks to provide some devastating
damage the culmination of all of robin's
progress can be seen during her fight
with black maria in demon blooming
something which is supposedly her new
greatest attack
in this she creates a giant demon-like
clone of herself complete with bat wings
and horns that was strong enough to hold
and knock out black maria with seeming
ease this ability also has a pretty good
secondary effect of intimidating any
lower level enemies if i was one of
kaido's grunts i probably wouldn't want
to be fighting the giant demon girl it
also has a tertiary effect of being
really poetic nod to the devil child
name that she was braided with by the
world government our 8th crew member is
the mechanical macho man himself frankie
when frankie was younger he had the
passionate
yet questionable idea to jump in front
of the sea train in an attempt to stop
it the accident injured him so badly
that he would have to replace the entire
front half of his body with machinery
making him a cyborg and obviously the
only reason he didn't change the back
half of himself is because he can't
reach back there it's too far his first
mechanical form the battle frankie 36
meant that he had superhuman strength
and that the front half of him was made
of metal and more or less impervious to
most kinds of damage his back however
remained a huge weak point in contrast
to that the cyborg body also allows him
to hide weapons and make alterations to
his body as well for example his stomach
holds a fridge with cola in it that
powers his body
unfortunately if this is replaced with a
different drink it will drastically
affect his personality for example tea
makes him a british gentleman
furthermore he can choose to consume
extra cola to launch powerful bursts of
air from his arms called kudavon other
attacks include things like strong right
which launches his right fist at enemies
and has it retracted later via a chain
that it's connected to frankie's centaur
extends the front half of his legs to
form a reverse centaur typically being
used to grapple his opponents to the
floor and open them up to a barrage of
punches he can shoot fire or nails from
his mouth shoot off his razor-sharp
sideburns he has shoulder cannons the
devastating ultimate hammer machine guns
in his left wrist a shield from his left
forearm as most powerful technique of
all
frankie invincible where he lays on his
back and makes it so as a weak point
can't be targeted
it's kind of lame but undeniably
effective post time skip we see his body
changing drastically as he becomes the
battle frankie 37
this form is
unique it's much bigger it has a lot
more weapons but also a bunch of just
for fun options again his back remains
untouched because it's too far now for a
few of the upgrades that frankie
received we see frankie changing his
hair to several different versions in
this form and some of which are even
functional in battle frankie can also
extend a smaller hand from his palm for
more delicate or precise works as his
new hands are massive or if he wants
more destructive force he can always use
the radical beam for that this is
effectively an upgrade of coup de vaughn
but rather than air it shoots a laser
frankie has rockets nipple lights he can
turn his legs into tank treads and in
general this form just offers frankie a
ton more power versatility and options
and as i said most importantly nipple
lights finally iron pirate general
frankie or battlefrankie38
is the power ranger like final form
right now frankie docks himself with the
black rhino and brachiotank this form is
still smaller than monster point but
it's pretty massive the iron pirate
offers the franken sword which is not
super useful as frankie's not a great
swordsman but it also gives him powerful
punches a drill that can pierce through
the heavens on its head and it is
extremely damage resistant to the point
where missiles barely do anything this
form in general has similar and upgraded
versions to frankie's other forms things
like machine guns rockets and of course
a massive cannon that he describes as
the sonny's gaon cannon on land
frankie's biggest gift is not his
usefulness on the battlefield though
it's instead his ability to be a
shipwright carpenter and mechanic he
keeps the sunny in top shape produces
weapons and repairs or creates whatever
the crew needs and we saw what happened
to mary so we know how vital his role is
especially in the new world while we've
seen him do some fantastic and amazing
things there is one that always stood
out to me as being hilarious and
literally above the rest frankie skywalk
was basically the moment that frankie
created fortnite as he made stairs right
into the sky to fight orbs we also see
him building bridges in that arc using
debris to make giant nunchucks and again
frankie just shows off that he is very
versatile and takes advantage of
anything in his surroundings he's a
character that creates opportunities and
allows his crew to not just perform to
their own potential but by creating what
they need in any given moment he also
allows them to rise above their
potential and succeed where they might
otherwise fail member number nine is the
soul king himself brooke brooke was part
of the rumbar pirates 52 years ago but
the entire group was wiped out when they
were stranded in the florian triangle
this including brook however he had
hidden the yomi yominomi which gave him
a second chance at life
unfortunately though when his soul was
looking for his body after coming back
it was unable to do so because it was
still lost in the triangle by the time
brook's soul found his body all that was
left was a skeleton even so the soul was
able to reanimate the body leaving brook
as a walking talking skeleton while
first seeming useless other than the
extra life brook eventually learns to
manipulate his own soul allowing it to
leave his body and to become a ghost he
can move through walls as well as sneak
into areas that might be unavailable
otherwise this control over his soul
also extends to things housing weaker
souls like homies lastly brook can
harness the chill of the underworld
allowing him to freeze things with his
sword or his aura and speaking of his
sword brook is the crew's second
swordsman he uses a cane sword called
soul solid and while zoro is more of a
samurai fighter brook uses a mixture of
fencing and the ido that he calls gentle
blade style his attacks tend to be much
more precise and speedy offering a lot
of power as a result beyond his
swordsmanship though brook has some
unique abilities to his skeletal body he
is so lightweight that he can run on
water kind of circumventing the weakness
to water that devil fruit users have
he's also resistant to heat cold
lightning and disease as he doesn't have
skin blood or organs he can survive
having his head cut off and he can just
heal from drinking milk when i think of
how strong brooke is in terms of the
crew i usually think of him as kind of
middle of the group somewhere just below
frankie and around usa and just like
with those characters while he
definitely offers a little bit of power
he has a secondary skill set that is
pretty invaluable and that is because
brooke is our cruise musician he
specializes in violin piano and guitar
but regardless of what he's playing he
can enchant his melodies to have effects
on those who hear them for example
making people fall asleep or hypnotizing
them into thinking that they're at some
kind of festival which if you can affect
an enemy with these things is pretty
valuable brook also has the role of
being in charge of keeping up morale on
the crew he uses music to lighten the
mood inspire or just generally cheer
people up you've probably gone in long
car rides you know how much music helps
but imagine days at sea with nothing
else to do and nothing to listen to i
would think it could be rough at times
even without the music brook's sense of
humor and larger than life personality
really help with raising the mood in
general and while not all of his jokes
might land we could probably do without
the 500th panty joke on average i'd say
the crew is extremely lucky to have him
with them and now on to our 10th and
final official crew member jinbei
was a former warlord and is now the
helmsman of the straw hats ever since on
fishman island jinbe has always kind of
felt like a character you meet in an rpg
who is way higher level than your party
but that you know you will eventually be
able to recruit and that's kind of
exactly what happens with him when luffy
meets jinbe he is a considerable
powerhouse definitely not able to take
on the admirals but even against them he
can kinda hold his own and protect
himself for the most part we even see
him taking the attack that killed ace
fairly well
not great but you know he survived we
see him standing toe to toe with moria
easily basically taking him down in one
shot and even big mom states that jinbe
leaving her crew would be a huge loss of
power for her jinbe is easily one of the
strongest fish men to appear in the
series so far even able to punch
wadatsumi into the air he's durable
enough to go through the baptizing and
impel down without flinching something
that the guards claim to be amazing
later taking a head-on sword swing from
big mom without really being damaged at
all and he's fast enough to keep up with
luffy in gear second even on land and
all of these abilities are significantly
amplified when he's underwater jinbe's
real power though comes from fishman
karate and even among fish men he is
considered a prodigy and a master having
received a black belt as a child jinbe
is so talented at fishman karate that
his punches don't even need to land
instead the water particles in the air
will react to his attack and send
enemies flying
even when we look at something like big
mom's crew we see him taking out the
officer's charlotte opera in one punch
beyond all of this his fishman karate
allows him to freely manipulate water
enabling him to throw it bend it or
shape it through his attacks even just
his water shot which is a basic
technique was miles stronger than hordy
jones's despite hordy being on energy
steroids basically jinbe is a brawler
he's a tank he's fast and he's a water
bender all of which combine to make him
quite a threat as a helmsman jinbe is
able to take advantage of his knowledge
of sea currents and general mastery of
the craft to allow him to surf the sunny
through a curling wave with frankie even
saying that jinbe would be able to bring
out sunny's full potential and the last
thing i want to mention with jinbei is
something that probably goes a bit
underappreciated and that's his ability
to speak a voice of reason jinbe is
level-headed tactful and
well-thought-out most importantly though
is his ability to translate those
thoughts and feelings towards others
especially on a diplomatic scale like he
had done with big mom or on an emotional
scale like he did with luffy after ace's
death and while characters like robin
nami zorro and to a lesser degree
frankie if he's in the mood to be
serious
might be able to do this kind of thing
as well jinbe's words seem to inherently
carry more weight to many people
worldwide luffy included now i do want
to quickly mention the two people who
literally carry the crew on their backs
as well because the mary and the sunny
are absolutely crewmates in their own
right the going mary was a caravel ship
one popular in the 15th century in our
world that offered a lot of
maneuverability and was small enough to
travel through rivers easily which are
great things but this lightweight design
also means
it's kind of fragile which we definitely
see with the mary we got the mary in
syrup village and she carried the crew
all the way to water 7 and annie's lobby
before she was finally put to rest the
merry was a very basic ship a few
cannons a lounge a room for the men and
one for the women and a storage room of
course we also saw her being given wings
going towards skypia as well but while
the mary didn't offer anything crazy
like the sunny wood it was a ship that
was loved by her crew and that loved
them back
so much so that a club outermon or ship
fairy appeared basically a sign that the
ship had been genuinely cared for we see
the cleveland appearing in both skypia
to repair the mary as well as bringing
the ship to annie's lobby to rescue the
crew and carry them one last time mary
was a simple ship but her crew was
reckless with her luffy crashed her into
icebergs zorro and sanji were stupid and
broke things all the time
but even so she was happy mary was
succeeded by the thousand sunny a ship
designed by frankie to be the greatest
ship in the world
unlike the mary which was a caraval the
sunny is a brigantine and this ship has
all the bells and whistles most
iconically is the soldier docking system
which houses compartments for the
soldiers of the sunny as frankie calls
them channel 0 has paddles on either
side of the ship allowing them to
progress even without wind or even
travel in reverse if needed channel 1
has a remodeled waiver channel 2 has the
mini mary a shopping boat channel 3 has
a submarine that looks like a shark the
shark submerged 3.
channel 4 has the black rhino channel 5
has the brachio tank and naturally
channel 6 has an inflatable pool just
like frankie himself the sunny can also
release a burst of air the coup de burst
a massive force that allows the sunny to
fly for a decent distance basically
allowing them to escape in a worst case
scenario the head of the sunny also has
some secrets as well chicken voyage sees
the mane of the lion becoming a
propeller that pushes the ship backwards
or the geon cannon which has the lion
opening its mouth and firing a massive
energy beam on the less battle oriented
side of things the sunny also has a boys
and a girls room but it also has a
kitchen a sick bay an aquarium a library
the usop factory frankie's workshop and
a crow's nest the main level also has a
garden for usopp's pop greens an area
for nami's tangerine grove and a flower
bed for robin the sunny is just an
all-around upgrade to the mary it offers
literally anything that the crew might
need and if it doesn't have something
frankie is able to add it and that leads
us to the last topic of this video the
honorary straw hat and best girl in the
series
vivi while not able to join the crew
because you know she's a princess and
whatnot vivi was made an honorary member
of the crew she began as miss wednesday
working for baroque works in order to
find out the true identity of mr zero
crocodile however once the straw hats
uncovered that she is actually princess
vivi nefertari she drops that disguise
pretty quickly phoebe can sometimes have
a pretty naive view of the world
expecting to be able to save everyone
and unable to accept that there would be
loss of any kind before she could
succeed she could be a little bit
entitled from time to time and she often
butted heads with luffy when it came to
making plans
but she genuinely cared about everyone
especially the straw hats for example
choosing to stop and find a doctor for
nami before going to alabasta to save
her people she has an amazing sense of
duty both to her country and to her
friends and in general is just a
genuinely good person similar to jinbe
she also has a very reasonable and
diplomatic view of the world
understanding that violence and pride
aren't always the answer for every
problem and that sometimes you're going
to need to bow your head if you want to
move forward despite that though vivi
was also not useless on the battlefield
she wasn't exactly the strongest
character and i doubt she progressed in
the same way as the rest of the crew
since she was left as princess but she
did manage to hold her own enough to
become a single-digit agent for baroque
works while she doesn't have much power
behind her attacks she's extremely agile
she's honestly pretty similar to nami
before she had access to weather
abilities rather than using a bose staff
like nami did though vivi used the
peacock slashers sharp bladed discs on a
wire that spun around her fingers and
were absolutely able to decapitate
someone if needed or if an enemy was too
strong or too fast for her she could
always try to stun her opponents with a
hypnotic dance using the patterns on her
clothes or her perfume scent in the
anime like i said vivi doesn't offer
much in terms of power but her
diplomatic skills as well as her ability
to win people over are worth just as
much in the right situation especially
when we consider the events of revelry
oh and also she has a pet duck and karu
is fantastic and what more do you really
need but there you have it a quick look
at all the straw hats how they fight and
what they offer the crew on a grander
scale some are more battle oriented some
are more support oriented but each
member of the crew brings with them a
talent that is necessary for the crew's
success which roommate is your favorite
and why and out of all the crew members
which one has your favorite attack skill
or ability finally if you were to join
the crew what would you bring to the
table let me know all those in the
comments down below and of course
remember to leave a like to let us know
to keep making one piece content you can
also subscribe to the channel which is a
totally free way of supporting us and
keeps you up to date on all anime uproar
content finally you can follow us over
on twitter at anime uproar or you can
follow myself over on my own channel
axel beats for now though thank you all
so much for watching and until next time
remember to stay excellent